es una de las jornadas más mortíferas
desde el golpe de estado a pesar de las
advertencias miles de personas se han
concentrado nuevamente en distintas
ciudades de mianmar contra la junta
militar que este sábado celebró el
llamado día de las fuerzas armadas
wang por el día de las fuerzas armadas
en mianmar es más bien el día en que
matan a la población con los fallecidos
de la jornada ya son más de 400 las
personas que han perdido la vida desde
el golpe de estado del 1 de febrero la
asociación para la asistencia de los
presos políticos afirma que alrededor de
un cuarto de las víctimas han muerto por
disparos en la cabeza lo que indicaría
una voluntad expresa de ejecutarlos con
la vista puesta en las movilizaciones
previstas para hoy la junta militar
difundió por la televisión estatal un
comunicado dirigido a los manifestantes
no mueran en vano sin embargo durante el
desfile el jefe de la junta militar me
now' cndc line condenó los actos
violentos de los manifestantes
al mismo tiempo que aseguró que su rol
es el de proteger la gente y promover la
democracia cuando levantemos las
disposiciones del estado de alarma
organizaremos adicciones libres y justas
para transferir las responsabilidades
gubernamentales aún así no aclaró la
fecha de los prometidos comicios por
otro lado el general ha agradecido la
presencia al actor de la delegación rosa
y ha calificado al país de verdadero a
mujer y es que moscú junto con beijing
bloquea en el consejo de seguridad las
resoluciones de la onu contra el país
tomado por los militares ambas naciones
fueron las únicas en enviar a sus
representantes a los eventos castrenses